ABCs of AI D is for deepmind deepmind is
alphabet's artificial intelligence
research arm the company is focused on
developing artificial general
intelligence a type of AI that can
reason and learn like humans do deepmind
has already made some large advances in
AI like Alpha fold a deep learning model
that was able to accurately predict
protein structures or Alpha Dev an AI
system that uses reinforcement learning
to discover faster sorting algorithms
and this is just the beginning
deepmind's research could one day
revolutionize many Industries like
energy transportation and Healthcare
check out the pinned comment for more
cool stuff related to deepmind what
other AI topics are you excited to learn
more about on the next episode of